Alright, so to get started showing you soem of the performance
techniques in Chrome Dev Tools, I want you to load up
the Dev Tools bar, and also check out this great HTML-5
game called Biolab Disaster. Now, I love this game. It's made
with a fantastic framework called Impact JS. And, happens to be
a lot of the motivation on how we did the Grits
Code Base back in the other course. Now, let's take a
look at what we have here. When we talk about performance,
we always talk about three pillars of performance. Network, render,
and compute. What we are going to talk today first
is the Network pillar. In order to get an understanding
of how your web application is loading, what resources are coming
down to the wire. And how long it's taking, but
first thing you need to do is open up the network
tab in Chrome Dev Tools. This is a fantastic GEM
and treasure trove of information.
Because basically, this actually records every
request that your web application is making to the server
enlisted here with a lot of very valid information. For example,
you can see what type it is, the status of
the request The content, how long it took to get it,
and when it came in in the overall request structure
of your entire loading sequence. Now, we could spend an entire
Udacity course actually going into the nuances of this tool
and how to use it, but instead I want to focus
on a couple Key things. First off, when you're talking
about loading web applications on mobile devices, there's two things
you need to worry about. The first is how many
requests you're actually making. So for instance, if you scroll down
for playbiolab.com, you can actually see that there's a lot
of assets that are being loaded here. Right? Every time
your phone has to grab one of these assets off
the Internet, a lot of things occur, but most importantly is,
it takes time away from loading your application. Mainly because the
medium to retrieve the data is a little bit slower than just
loading it, say, off the memory or off of the disk.
Now, the second thing you need to be concerned about is actually
the size of the content that you're trying to load. So
if you go over here to the size button, and you actually
click on it twice, it's actually going to sort all of the assets
that you requested by their size. Now, notice right here, this top
one actually has two megabytes. Now look at
That's a single OG file. Of course that's going to
be music. But basically that's two megabytes that
has to be downloaded before this web application could
be played. Now, did you know that according
to http archive, the average website size is only
1.1 megabytes? So already this single asset is
larger than most of the websites on the web.
Listen, that's not going to help you load this on your mobile device
any faster. So by sorting it by size you can get a great
sense of what assets you have, what sizes they are and see the
relative proportion on how long it takes those assets to actually be loaded.